a fan of uh like medieval times you know
the the who's not who's not
i don't i i i'm not saying i'm not a fan
right i'm not saying i'm not a fan i've
just never been i was never interested
in like eating a big turkey
leg it's amazing
wait a minute
i shall joust you sir
all right man i wish we had two horses
loaded up backstage and funnily enough
bring them on
[Laughter]
two minutes later i'm dead
uh so yeah so you like you like going
you like do you dress up you know the
medieval times it's where you go and
then you know and you sit around there's
arena and nights come out and and i my
mum and dad come over occasionally to
stay with me over here and when they
come up i rack my brains for things that
they'll be interested in doing that'll
be fun and so one year i i heard about
this place medieval times now i thought
my mom and dad are going to love this my
mom and dad do enjoy dressing up my dad
frustrated actor
and any chance to put a costume on he's
there so i found out about medieval
times and i got a bunch of friends my
daughter as well and a whole bunch of
people and i said the point is with
medieval times you have to dress up
in medieval outfits and then we'll go
and and it'll be great
no one does dress up
that's right apart from the people who
work right the people who work there
dress up but the people who go there
don't no so you show up yeah so i i
hired a bus
i played medieval music on the bus and
we all sat on the bus in our outfits
and then we got there went in nobody
dressed up at all
and then i laughed and laughed
as everyone kind of went what but then
you've sort of stepped over the line you
you have to invent you really have to go
for it exactly and it works brilliantly
then i found out the next door there's
one called pirate adventure
i have only been to pirate adventure
three times
pirate adventure and so that's obviously
the same thing all pirate themed and you
dress up for that you get dressed up as
pirates put a fake yeah on your shoulder
yeah yeah yeah clearly dress up as
powers go there now why aren't there
more i've run out now
why aren't there more there should be
more i don't know why isn't there a
western one or a science fiction one
also or a conan one well okay
i'd make a fortune everyone with on
stilts with extraordinary
ocean wave like yeah you get a hair when
you show up you put it on you get put on
stilts
the food would be awful
that would be the worst and then you're
four everyone is forced to strip naked
halfway through no no no one wants to
see that um thanks for backing me up on
that uh
you could have been like no we want to
but no they did they did they were
apparently like we do not want no no no
you did the right you're honest they did
the thing when i say i'm old now yeah
they did they did they all looked aside
the whole audience full